-Welcome, everybody!
Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show."
This is it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We made it.
And even though I just got here,
I can already tell
you guys are way better
than last night's audience.
Yeah. Absolutely.
Absolutely.
And you're actually here
on a very special night,
because, guys, tonight
is our fifth anniversary.
That's right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
That's right.
We launched the show
exactly five years ago,
and as of tonight,
we'll have made 1,022 episodes
of "The Tonight Show."
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's crazy, right?
I can't believe
that it's been five years.
Can you believe that?
-Actually I can, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you very much, Higgins.
Here's a fun fact.
Tarik, tell everyone
what you told me earlier.
Tarik?
[ Laughter ]
Year six off to a great start.
Here we go.
Can we try that again?
Dave, can we do it again?
-No problem, Jimmy.
-All right, thanks.
I'm gonna go from the
"fifth anniversary" line, okay?
It's the magic of television,
guys.
We'll edit this out.
[ Laughter ]
Guys, tonight
is our fifth anniversary.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
That's right!
We launched the show
exactly five years ago,
and as of tonight,
we will have done 1,022 episodes
of "The Tonight Show."
[ Cheers and applause ]
And check this out.
Tarik, tell the everyone
what you told me earlier.
-Uh, in dog years, we're
actually at 7,154 episodes.
-Wow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
No wonder why I'm so tired.
Now let's get to some news here.
If you watched
the Oscars last night,
allow me to explain.
I'm what's called a host.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's right, last night
were the Academy Awards.
It's when Hollywood
gathers together
to celebrate all
the incredible films nobody saw.
It's great.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-These --
These are the jokes?
Unbelievable.
-...limo saying, "I just want
to take another look at you."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Of course, there were some
interesting winners last night.
For example, the Oscar
for Best Animated Short
Went to Kim Jong-un.
-Oh, really? Wow.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Didn't even know
he was nominated.
-He's very animated.
-Wow.
-Speaking of Kim Jong-un,
later this week,
he's meeting
with President Trump.
They have a lot in common --
they inherited everything
from their dads,
and they cut their own hair.
[ Laughter ]
That's right --
Trump's going to Vietnam.
-Does he look, uh...
puffy?
-Too much salt.
-Ow.
-The meeting's from...
-Let's get all the ramen
out of his office.
-...Trump and Kim Jong-un,
their translator
will just
slowly walk into the ocean.
[ Laughter ]
But I really wish cameras
were allowed in the room
for that meeting,
'cause I'd love to see Trump
try to say the phrase
"nuclear prolipf-- prolip --"
Oh, God.
[ Laughter ]
"Nuclear proliferation."
Sorry.
Uh, I wish cameras were there,
allowed in the room
for that meeting, yeah,
'cause I'd love to see Trump
try to say the phrase
"nuclear polar--"
I can't say it.
[ Laughter ]
How's he gonna say it
if I can't say it?!
[ Laughter ]
Cut that joke.
We don't need that joke.
[ Laughter ]
Hey!
Uh...
[ Laughter ]
Five years, five years, yeah.
Some entertainment news --
a new Jean-Claude Van Damme...
-This is
an old person to you, right?
This guy looks old?
-"We Die Young"
is about what'll happen
if Trump's meeting if
Kim Jong-un doesn't go well.
-At least he still
combs his hair with a sneaker.
-Get this -- the AARP...
-That's young.
-...reality show
called "Date My Grandma."
[ Audience groans ]
Like "The Bachelorette,"
but instead of a fantasy suite,
they get a booth at Denny's.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Oh, my God. I hate myself
for writing that joke.
-Yeah, I think we all hate you
-Yeah. You should quit.
-Mm-hmm.
-Hey, I saw that Facebook
recently celebrated
its 15th anniversary.
I can't believe
it's been around for so long.
Do you remember what it was like
before Facebook?
You remembered
your friends' birthdays
'cause you actually cared.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Bang.
[ Rimshot ]
[ Laughter ]
Before Facebook, you spent time
at work actually working.
[ Rimshot ]
Before Facebook,
the only way to find out
your uncle was racist
was seeing him on Thanksgiving.
[ Rimshot ]
Finally, you guys,
a new report found
that the New York Knicks
are the NBA's most valuable team
at $4 billion.
That's crazy.
That's a billion dollars
for every game
they've won this year.